what's going on everybody welcome to
another flash tutorial video this is a
first video in a sort of batch of flask
videos that I'll be adding to the
previous series in this video we're
gonna be talking about includes so it
has been a little bit since we last
talked about flask so just in case you
don't have the files you can go to
github.com slash Python programming and
once you're there you can scroll on down
to here Python program website and these
are the files you can download the zip
extract it move the files up or you can
get all that fancy stuff so do whatever
you need to do get the files you don't
necessarily have to use the files if
you've got your own little project and
you're just trying to learn alongside
your own project and incorporate it
that's cool you should have no problem
following along so we'll move this over
and we'll go ahead and get started so
there will be all the sample code is
posted up on Python program and will
actually be referencing especially in
this tutorial series because there's a
lot of HTML code and me sitting here and
typing out the HTML code making you type
out the HTML code is really stupid so
we're not going to be doing that so
though you'll definitely want to head to
the text-based tutorial and grab that
code so these will be kind of little
faster paced as well since we don't have
to linger on the HTML so you can come
here web dev and then scroll down
they'll be new tutorials here as they
are released so moving on let's get
started so first of all here's our ended
up pi file one thing to notice right out
of the gate is actually let me close
this one and open up again let's go here
in it pi is you know down here we've got
these little mini functions this was my
content management system my initial
thought was that I would have like
custom tutorial for every tutorial but
very quickly you get into a sort of
habit and because you need to keep
things efficient so this was a mistake
and the real way to handle this is with
dynamic URLs so as you might be able to
guess that'll be
one of the videos in this little batch
is doing dynamic URLs to kind of handle
for this nonsense
and the other stuff is a mystery you'll
find out as we go so just go ahead and
find a spot it really doesn't matter
where you stuff this I'm trying to find
a good one that I can just copy and
paste yeah we'll just do this so just
take one of these functions basically
copy come down here paste and we'll
rename this so this will be will call
this include example and then we'll take
that same name put it there
we'll leave the try and accept no
problem we don't need a garbage collect
and now we'll make a new template and
we're gonna call this one includes
tutorial HTML save that come over here
go into templates new file and this will
be includes H whoops what do we call
this I already forgot includes tutorial
by HTML all right so now I've got an
empty file here I'm going to take 404
here we'll copy that
come over here paste and basically clean
this up because this is a bit of a mess
we'll leave the div container I don't
need to align anymore that whoops all
right cool
so now within this div we're gonna put
well just have it say hi for now it
doesn't really matter where that'll be
changed in a moment we'll save that come
over to in it we've got in it loading
includes tutorial no problem
so now we'll come over to the shell and
this is what I've been reloading is that
they're using to kind of refresh Apache
in the past I use a service Apache to
refresh I think but reload goes a lot
faster so I'm pretty sure service Apache
to or no we were using restart I new
refresh sounded weird right but it Oh
first of all that failed probably had to
probably have to do a sudo there since
I'm not a super user here but anyway
reload is generally a lot faster for
some reason restart is
pretty slow so reload is usually like
instant now this is my little server
here you might be hosting locally or
whatever it's probably best that you dev
locally but I just use this server
temporarily so so here's our server it
basically it's like an old version of
Python programming net and we are our
link is include example so paste that on
in there sure enough there's our
information now of course we haven't
actually included a thing
come on Harrison worst tutorial ever so
let's go ahead and include some stuff so
we'll come back over here this is
actually extending but it's not
including Jake so to include something
all you change is it is its logic so
it's the curly brace with the % and you
include so you just type include and
then in string you include whatever you
want to include now like extend and
render template it automatically knows
to look in templates okay
but with includes generally like right
now our templates we don't have that
many templates but as you build a web
site you're gonna find you've got like
60 templates or something right and so
it makes sense to cache try to start
structuring things so we're gonna go
here add a new directory and I'm gonna
call this includes so all my little HTML
snippets they go and includes so include
it's already in template so all we have
to do is includes slash and then
whatever we want to include now we're
going to include a comment box so I'm
just gonna call it comment box tight
HTML save that now right now we're gonna
obviously get an error because comment
box I HTML simply does not exist so
let's go ahead and go to includes we'll
just open that up nothing here yet well
new file and comment box HTML empty file
and we'll start by let's go ahead and
just copy this so head to the link and
grab the comment box dot HTML at least
the initial one okay and you don't have
to even do it really but if you want if
you want to follow along approach to do
so here what's happening is we're using
logic within here and this is this is
actually like a global basically like
everyone has access to the session
information so this isn't too fancy yet
but I'll show you something more
impressive about includes in a moment so
here's our comment box if the idea here
is that if the user is logged in then
they should be able to have a little
reply blocks box so they can post a
reply if they're not logged in they get
a little message that says you need to
log in if you want a post and then cut
right so simple enough we'll save that
and let's just check that real quick
what did I do here it is so we can
refresh and I'm not currently logged in
such as you have to be logged in to post
okay great let's login now I'm logged in
and let me just hit back a couple times
and then refresh and boom we've got a
reply box awesome now we also had one
more thing we wanted obviously it was
the reply box and replies so we need
some replies so again to get some
replies let's head over to the sample
code basically and we've got a little
dictionary here you bring that back get
back here
alright now an include example we try
the following we're gonna add this this
dictionary here so this is this is just
a simple dictionary with these are in
theory our users in our posts now you
would have some sort of SQL query that
grabs replies to the specific post but
we don't have anything like that in our
database and that's a lot to add for
such a simple tutorial so this is just a
quick example so we take replies
obviously this is a variable that we
want to pass not really to includes
tutorial we want to pass that - comment
box right so how do we do that well it
turns out we don't really need to do
that so whoops
we do replies equals replies and we go
to the HTML file here and now what's
happening
we are this is what it replies is being
passed to but it turns out it's also
passed here dynamically so we can come
to comment box and basically after the
if statement because whether or not the
user is logged in we still want to show
previous replies so we would do
something like this like we would say
something like you know for our in
replies and then we can end the four and
four there we go we want to have some
sort of comment and this is just a
really easy thing let's say div class
well and then we'll have a well again
Earth div yes so the real reason I don't
type HTML because I suck at and then
basically you would have you've got the
reply so the reply it's an applied
dictionary right so it would be replies
are is the actual reply itself and then
the reply or would just be the are right
so far and then I'll just have a dash or
something okay so that will display for
everyone so we can save that now we need
to save the in it file and then also we
need to refresh so we do that cool now
head over to here and we will restart or
refresh this and bam we've got all the
replies there so obviously this is just
a really quick and simple example this
is a horrible comment and stuff but the
idea is to show you the includes
basically so so really that's it I mean
there's really the includes is a pretty
simple concept to digest so that should
be it but if you have any questions
comments whatever feel free to leave
them below the next tutorial we'll be
talking about ginger more ginger logic
basically so there's a lotta little
subtleties with ginger that took me a
really long time to actually learn all
these little subtleties people don't
seem to really talk much about them or
explain why they're using them so I've
kind of had to figure that out on my own
so I think that'll be kind of helpful
for you guys to cover that and then
we'll begin getting into even more
cool stuff so anyways questions
constantly below otherwise as always
thanks for watching things for all the
support subscriptions until next time